this happened at a car wash russian
rockets hit a structure that included a
repair facility three people were killed
four others were treated in hospital
here in eastern ukraine there's been a
definite uptick in the number of missile
and rocket attacks over the last few
days and in kiev this morning the
capital was targeted for the first time
since early june
it's now a daily experience somewhere in
ukraine as civilians remain in the
russian firing line
there were at least four large
explosions in the center of the city
in this apartment building rescuers
worked to save a seven-year-old girl she
was sleeping peacefully until a cruise
missile hit her home said the country's
foreign minister it's the second time
this apartment has been attacked
rescuers were busy saving residents at
another building
and at a different location someone
stuck under broken concrete screamed for
help the city's mayor was at the scene
we know the couple of people inside
at yet another location in kiev a large
blast left a crater in a kindergarten
playground all as russia continues to
deny it's targeting civilians
claiming its army is hitting three
ukrainian military training locations on
sunday
this just days after ukrainian forces
retreated from sivera donesk the eastern
city once home to 100 000 people is now
entirely under russian control
thank you to the soldiers who evacuated
us from there says this woman named
elena she and others are now out and on
their way to a safer place russia
celebrates his biggest victory in this
war since the capture of mario paul last
month
sean o'shea global news kharkiv ukraine